[Musique]
au printemps 2007
le niveau du lac saint-jean frôlé 18 kg
et des résidences sont menacés d'autres
sont évacués des citoyens installe des
sacs de sable
chez rio tinto on surveille de près la
situation comme gestionnaires de
barrages
l'entreprise doit informer la population
des risques liés à la crue des eaux
et pour l'aider dans son travail rio
tinto a pu compter pour la première fois
sur un nouvel outil informatique apple
la pieuvre omar l'information avec ses
pattes 4g à l'information et à la dessus
cet outil c'est le ji octopus développé
par l'entreprise nucci mythe ni pour de
saguenay l'application ne permet
évidemment pas d'empêcher les
inondations mais elle permet de limiter
les dégâts à partir d'une prévision
météo
rio tinto anticipe quel niveau le lac
st-jean atteindra recommande par la
neige au sol
les précipitations observées et
évidemment les prévisions météo
l'application permet ensuite à
l'entreprise de savoir quelle honte
précises seront inondées
si la prévision se concrétise le lac est
en bleu et puis ça c'est les niveaux qui
pourraient les ondes pour être nombreux
grâce à l'intégration des données du
registre foncier
on peut aussi savoir à qui appartiennent
les terrains où les bâtiments qui seront
touchées et en avertir les propriétaires
justin impoli de personnes à roger qui
l'a 75 habitants dedans c'est pas même
chose qu une maison unifamiliale au
nombre de 37 personnes que tu peux y
avoir est-ce que des hôpitaux qui ont
inondé un pas pour aider les communautés
aux prises avec des crues
exceptionnelles
l'entreprise a choisi de rendre son
outil accessible à toutes les
municipalités du territoire
ils peuvent à partir de la navigation
sur l'outil sortir une liste d'adressés
qui sont concernés ils sont dans la zone
potentiellement impactés
et puis donner sans leur chef pompier
les gens pour prévoir les évacuations
pour la professeure de géographie pascal
peyron développer une meilleure
connaissance du territoire devrait être
la priorité du gouvernement
cette connaissance l'ensemble pour
l'ensemble du territoire est absolument
fondamentale d'une part avoir et d'autre
part à transmettre c'est vraiment le
concept de rendre l'information
accessible aux citoyens
on a des outils de surveillance en
continu de la météo au ministère de la
sécurité publique ont disposent déjà
d'outils numériques pour suivre l'état
des cours d'eau pourrait-on faire pour
l'ensemble du québec ce que rio tinto a
fait au saguenay-lac-saint-jean qui peut
avoir une bonification par un échange
d'informations sur les outils qui sont
mis en place
c'est pour une solution unique qui peut
être répandu partout il faut vraiment
s'assurer que des actions soient prises
rapidement
chose certaine croit la professeur
pascal biron il faut faire vite
c'est dans les deux années suivant une
crue des eaux exceptionnelle que
l'opinion publique la plus favorable aux
investissements publics pour contrer la
répétition d'événements semblables
[Musique]